thank you for joining us America Kate is
in Tampa hi Kate how are you I'm okay
how are you better than I deserve what's
up
um I'm in charge of the finances and my
family it's my husband and my two year
old daughter and myself and I bought the
financial piece planner actually can't
attend the classes because my husband's
the military and I'm a teacher and it's
just too late during the day and I was
sitting down with my husband going over
it and explained to him and try and set
up a budget and you know talk to him
about it and he makes jokes about it
and I'm really I'm really fearful
because he is being deployed in October
and we're very deeply in debt and I just
don't know how what to do to get him to
take it seriously and I'm a big part of
it because I don't know how to tell him
though
so I'll let him buy stuff or gotten by
and stuff because I'm not good at
telling no how old are you guys
29 and 30 well you know here's the thing
I don't know exactly what you say to him
but here's the message that you need to
deliver that you have no desire to be
his mother mm-hmm I don't be your mother
tired of being your mother you're not a
little boy you're a full grown man and I
need you to act like it
and a full grown man who's willing to
put his life on the line for the sake of
this country also should put his life on
the line for his wife mm-hmm
somebody's telling that yeah okay I kind
of bordered on that cuz I've broken down
into tears over the amount of debt we
have and living basically paycheck to
paycheck and I'll think oh good last six
hundred dollars left over at the end of
this month and I'm trying to put your
finger in the dike you're trying to put
your finger in the dam that's leaking
it's going to bust and run over the top
of you because you two aren't working on
together he's screwing this whole thing
up faster than you can fix it mm-hmm
because you won't tell him no and he's
acting a little boy
and he needs to be a man mm-hmm
now he doesn't need to become a nerd and
do the accounting he's not going to do
accounting you're by nature more
accounting and nerdy than he is mm-hmm
so you're always going to be the one
that writes the checks but you don't
need to be the only adult in the house
mm-hmm and that's the way this is going
down am I being too blunt I know that's
everything that I see that I can't tell
him then you need to tell him mm-hmm
honey you're getting ready to be
deployed I have no desire to manage life
by myself while you're deployed or while
you're here I desperately need you to be
a man and stand up and help me make
these decisions for our life it's not
funny and it's not cute that you won't
do a budget and you run around saying
mama won't give me money is you know
what are you 12 yeah they call me the
office commander this job series well
since I won't let him have money so well
they are a bunch of children mm-hmm that
he's working with and they've got some
growing up to do too
mm-hmm and that's what you're facing
here so he's got to man up hmm
I mean I we work with military all the
time it's a bunch of young guys and
they're studs they're awesome young gals
they're awesome people and they put
their life on the line for this country
and we appreciate them on the one hand
on the other hand some of them do stupid
on steroids hmm it's like because
they're they're so manly in their
warrior self that when they get home
they have to be a little boy and they
can't do that you're not the off-base
commander I don't want to be your
off-base commander I didn't marry
somebody that I wanted to manage so I'm
telling you pick a fight mm-hmm that's
what I'm telling you because here's
what's going to happen if you don't five
years from now seven years from now
three years from now you're going to
have had enough and the switch is going
to flip and you're going to leave and
there won't be no getting you back
because you won't you you will go over
the edge on this relationship I've done
financial counseling for 30 years I've
met so many women that their husbands
wouldn't
and up they wouldn't man up they
wouldn't man up they wouldn't man up and
finally she's had it and you can't reel
her back in for nothing she's gone
because once you've had it you've had it
you're right mm-hmm I've seen it I've
seen time and time again you've been
married you've been married six years
haven't you I for one you got all the
symptoms mm-hmm you got all the symptoms
you're the right age group and
everything and you got it three to five
years before this blows up on average if
you don't fix it you can hold your
breath you've been holding your breath
all this time acting like it's all okay
and you're walking around being the only
adult in the house and you're carrying
all the fear because you're the only
ones being responsible and he's had a
line kid oh I'm telling you you don't
put him on the phone I'll talk to him
he's still at work okay well you can
tell me as a new jerk in his life and
it's me as much as I love him and
appreciate him for defending this
country I'm also going to take him to
task on his husband skills cuz ain't
there now if you can't get through to
him and the two you can't have a
conversation that brings him around you
need to go see a marriage counselor
mm-hmm you know we've done that before
and it seems like he doesn't he doesn't
respond he'll sit there quietly and not
say anything so it's a one-way
conversation which four makes me even
more upset to end up just walking away
because I can't deal with it and I do
everything on my own again and then I
look at our bills and our outgoing money
and then and then again you reach the
end of your rope and you call me hmm and
then again you're gonna reach the end of
the rope but my point is you're gonna
reach the end of your rope one time and
there won't be no getting you back so
you need to tell him you need to tell
him that he's on a path to you know
we're on a track here the trajectory of
our marriage is that it ends mm-hmm and
we don't know that's not tomorrow and
I'm not threatening you
but you need to get the idea here Bubba
that we're gonna have to work together
we're gonna have to both be adults
because I'm completely done with you
being a little boy hmm
call his manhood out mm-hmm cuz I am
yeah that's your only shot because this
is not going to get better and
this issue gets better in your house and
I can't I can't make him grow up and you
can't make him grow up he's got to
decide to go okay she's serious this is
no longer cute it's no longer something
joke about what my buddies at work that
she's the commander I'm not going to
talk about that the base command we're
not gonna do that anymore all of a
sudden I'm just going to be a man and
I'm going to serve my wife and walk with
her yes you'll be writing the checks
because you're always the one that does
the numbers but we're going to make
decisions together as two grown-up
adults about our money in about our
future and about our life mm-hmm and you
know and when that happens you're you
know you're going to have a whole new
husband mm-hm
but and it can happen he can just decide
to do that tomorrow and here's the thing
he's not a bad guy yeah he's just fallen
into the trap of being typical and
normal you know the number one cause of
divorce in North America today
money fights and money problems why new
stuff like I'm talking about right here
the guy won't man up or the girl decides
she's a princess and and she needs a
daddy instead of a husband mm-hmm it's
the opposite of what you're facing you
know the number-one issue I'm having is
I'm I keep telling the hand over his
credit cards I've had that I paid that
thing off no no no his mother tells him
to hand over his credit cards when he
decides he's a man he decides what to do
with his credit card mm-hmm
quit being his mother okay I'm tired of
being your mother mm-hmm I didn't marry
a man not to be his mother every time
you say something like that you're
giving him as allowance the guys at work
are making fun cuz you're the base
commander I'm telling him he's got to do
this
I'm telling me he's got it all you're
doing is mother in this little boy
mm-hmm it's time for him to stop it the
hope that helps you kiddo it does thank
you so much hold on the line I'm going
to send you a copy of the book the Total
Money Makeover in case some of this gets
through and you guys have a better thing
to work from than the financial piece
planner it's not as good so it's a
decent workbook but this is a better
book I'll give it to you hold on and
tell him I said thanks for serving this
country but man up you Tom Dave Ramsey
said that
we have a manhood crisis in this culture
completely were safai the males in this
culture it's ridiculous some of you guys
need to stand up really some of you
women too
I mean it's just my gosh we have the
emotional maturity of 12 year olds
walking around adult bodies out there
this is crazy y'all you think she's the
only one no she's that's a normal
situation then let's scare the crap out
of you it should this is the Dave Ramsey
show
Oh